- After surviving breast cancer,
our next guest has made it her mission
to make major strides, literally,
in raising money and awareness
to fight this horrible disease.
Sharael Kolberg is running 50 miles
for 50 days in 50 states,
all in the name of finding a cure.
And Sharael joins me now.
Hi, Sharael!
- Hi, Drew.
Hi, thank you so much for having me.
I'm so happy to be here.
- Oh, Sharael, we really
wanted to make a whole segment
out of this because I was
blown away by your story.
So much so, there's just
a lot to talk about.
How are you feeling now?
What's your latest diagnosis?
How is everything?
- I'm doing great.
I have been cancer-free
since last December.
Doing great, living life, yeah.
Living every day to the
moment, so it's awesome.
- Oh, that's so wonderful.
You really are an inspiration
in every single aspect
of life, health and wellness,
mental space, philanthropy.
And what sort of was the
running piece of the puzzle?
What made that click for you?
- Well, I've always been a runner,
and when I was going through treatment
there were days when I literally
could not even get out of bed.
So for me, it was really
important to get back to running,
to make me feel normal again.
And it's a great way
to get people involved
and promote breast cancer awareness
and give people hope.
So it's been great.
I love running, and it's
a great way to get out,
get exercise, mental
health, physical health.
It's all good.
- I will say that you have
truly incentivized here.
Sometimes, you know, we don't really know
how to get involved,
and the way that you've
presented your website
and the challenge, I scoured through it,
I am very excited to
try to join you on this.
But first I have a very
exciting announcement.
I would like to introduce someone to you.
- Okay.
- So we all think what you're doing here
is just so important, and this is Jill
from none other than, get ready
for this, Bank of America.
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
Drop the mic.
Jill, thank you so much
for coming on the show.
Why is it important for
you to be here today?
- Thank you, Drew.
Thank you for having me,
it's so great to be here.
And Sharael, my colleagues
and I at Bank of America
have been following your story,
and we're so impressed by all
the work that you're doing
and the commitment that you've made
to raise awareness around breast cancer
and give so much hope to so many.
So to thank you for
running 50 miles in 50 days
with partners across 50 states,
in your honor, we're gonna
donate $50,000 to Susan G. Komen.
- Oh, my god.
(Drew screaming)
(Drew clapping)
Are you serious?
That's amazing, thank you so much.
You're gonna help save so many lives.
That is amazing.
- You know what?
- I can't thank you enough.
- Actually, that's not all.
Jill, is there something else?
- [Sharael] What?
- There's just one more thing.
I mean, this year has
just been so unprecedented
in so many ways, and your
story is even more inspiring,
and in the hopes that one
day no one has to face
a breast cancer diagnosis alone,
so in celebration of your
50th-birthday milestone,
we're gonna donate another
$50,000 for a total of $100,000.
- That's $100,000!
(audience clapping)
- Thank you so much.
That means so much to me
and for all those women
that are battling this terrible disease,
you're gonna help find a cure.
Thank you so much.
- And Jill, I cannot thank you enough
for this incredible opportunity.
You are our hero.
And, Sharael, you have inspired me.
I'm gonna post the website on our site.
I'm joining you.
I'm gonna try to run the
mile by October 31st.
October is Breast Cancer Awareness Month,
and so in honor of you, our pod, our squad
is gonna start the mission.
We're gonna start a Facebook group,
and we wanna do this with you.
I've never run a mile in my life.
I'm so excited.
- Thank you.
- Everybody get involved.
(upbeat music)